from hippie Haven to drug-free zone a
town in deep blue Washington state is
now outlawing drug use after a Statewide
push towards decimalization led to
surging fentanyl deaths the progressive
city of Bellingham saw 223 overdoses in
just three months City officials had
enough and voted to make open drug use
and arrestable crime something I agree
with
um
judge as you think about the legality
this and how this thing evolved here did
they do the right thing and should they
have done it sooner and what can we
expect going forward well I think the
mistake was made when they decided that
they were going to allow for these open
drug areas and then what they saw was an
increase not only in the amount of drug
uses but in the deaths a spiraling
increase in in the deaths and I think of
five-year-old dying in fentanyl is
really what made it uh unpalatable for
them any any longer so they're
criminalizing what they had
decriminalized I mean shock the
decriminalization didn't work but the
Curious part of the whole thing is that
the Biden Administration has what they
call harm reduction strategy where Biden
is putting out five million dollars to
create safe injection sites and the two
areas where they're going to do it is
outside of NYU in New York City and
Brown in Providence Rhode Island okay so
what's going to happen there is they're
going to have all of these open air
drugs sites and people are going to be
dying and fornicating and defecating
just like they do on the streets and
then they're going to say gee that
wasn't a good idea but in the end
um I think what we need to do is
recognize that we've got a real problem
in this country China doesn't have the
problem China in fact is sending a lot
of its uh fentanyl over to Mexico and
then to us do you know that it is a
death penalty crime in China to be
involved in drug trafficking and they
are they are similarly uh harsh when it
comes to drug use and the drug use they
end up sending you to a isolation camp
for two years you know the last thing we
need to do is decriminalize anything and
maybe do what China is doing not the
death penalty but we've got to get rid
we've got to get rid of some of this
should we decriminalize these or she
said did we undo these decriminalization
laws here in America around use of
cannabis and others oh is Greg going to
take it on the chin again what do you
mean I never do every once in a while
you guys are talking about
decriminalization like an idiot and this
is one of those moments use your facts
Jesse Focus did it again we did this
story last year in Portland when
Portland did the same thing in Oregon
and then all of these over deaths this
explosion of the homelessness what
caused that and then another town in
Washington D criminal it caused that and
they have an explosion in overdoses and
everyone's dying on drugs what caused it
would you America like to live in a city
run by Judge Jeanine and her Chinese
anti-drug cohorts
Portlandia with Greg Gutfeld as mayor
where everybody just piles up dead on
the streets but everyone's having a good
problem with cable I don't want to live
in either of those places I want to live
in a normal place like in New Jersey
there's no drugs in Jersey
you guys are conflating
decriminalization with legalization I'm
not for decriminalization I'm for
legalization decriminalization has no
effect on the supply hence the overdoses
the person who mistakes one pill for
another the heroin that's mixed with
fentanyl that is due to the fact that
the drugs are unsafe legalizing creates
a commercial safe product of what was a
statistic I think 50 000 people died
during prohibition because they were
mixing industrial alcohol to make drinks
that went away once it was legalized all
right you're conflating illegal with
legal you would be really mad if we did
that with Firearms wouldn't we get those
illegal drugs off the streets get these
illegal guns off the street now we're
talking about distinctions police called
do 11 overdose reports in one day you're
making my point that's a lot of Overdose
you just made my point there wouldn't be
overdoses if it was a commercially Safe
products for you every time that go so
one inch down the road you want to go to
everybody starts no no you're talking
about decriminalization which is oh my
God there's no legalization
we want a black market and make money
there will always be those people that's
why you make a real Market Danny would
you give us some some yeah just a couple
of things one so in this town of
Bellingham 223 people died in three
months two of them were under the age of
five so the cut that you imagine you're
in your local news you wake up every day
imagine in three months 223 people have
died and you think okay we have to do
something so while this debate is is it
is interesting and we've been actually
having it for 12 years right that I've
been on before that so while we're
having this debate the fentanyl deaths
are doubling every year okay and if it
goes like that then you have communities
that are spiraling out of control and
people feeling like I don't know how to
help my son my daughter my kid my
brother they're out on the street and
communities are they're having a fight
of paper
um and communities are spiraling
I I don't know what the answer is I just
know that if you have fennel dust
doubling like this yeah people are going
to want answers quickly and one of the
first things I want to do is say okay
well we should criminalize the thing
about legalization is that I could see
it actually making sense and my I'm like
this could work but then look what
California and New York did on cannabis
they screwed it up they only went 75 of
the way there so now the black market is
still underway and you can't use any
sort of credit card there so it's all
cash right and all those businesses are
being how do I know that data
Wall Street Journal you know Greg with
respect your argument reminds me of what
the Communists say well communism has
never been tried yet if it was only
tried
actually legalization hasn't been tried
it's called alcohol
and you drink a lot of it I can't over
Virginia I have as many rounds as I want
I still am alive I wish we had these
guys arguing for reparations
coming up next President Biden setting
his sights on your dishwasher and in
order to save the planet I want to Brian
kill Mead I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the anyway
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now